I think you are also raising the genre
with atomic blonde it's pretty amazing
and I know you've been producing it and
developing it for years and you would
tell me you were really interested in
finding a protagonist who was
unapologetic and could play by the same
rules as men which I love and what I'm
wondering is I know you must get a
million scripts sent to you all the time
was there a lack of that were you
finding that you something you had to go
out and develop yourself to make it
happen you know I just I wanted
something very specific and I think when
you are looking for something that
specific you I mean I was open to
landing on my lap but that wasn't
happening and I was about to turn 40 so
kind of took matters in my own hands and
said why not actively go with my
production company and search for
something like this so once we read a
couple of pages of that it was an
unpublished graphic novel at the time
there was definitely I saw great
potential on this character to have the
ability to live and breathe in a world
where she could play by the same rules
that men get to play all the time and
that was something that I really loved
yeah what else is it about Lorraine I
feel like one of the things I've heard
from you before is we don't learn a lot
about her backstory she she's sort of an
enigma and that gun that's totally okay
and that sort of falls into what you're
talking about I love it yeah I love it I
love that you know I think sometimes we
can you know when when a story doesn't
quite work I find that the female
characters in the movie will always be
the ones that are used to then
emotionally manipulate in a way that men
don't get used in that way
meaning that you know we're known to be
nurturers and we might not be thought of
as just warriors so we need a reason to
become a warrior and I have a problem
with that because we really are warriors
and we it's time for us to be shown that
way
we don't need to lose a child or to lose
a husband or to have some kind of a
revenge story in order to become a
warrior I think that's so it's it's not
today
and I love that about Lorraine I love
that Lorraine lives and breathes in this
world and she's just she exists she
simply her and we don't ever over
explain why she exists or why she's any
good at her job or anything I got she's
just she's there and I love that about
her yeah I was going to ask you what
some of your biggest pet peeves were
about the way Hollywood writes women and
it basically just explained I mean they
just put like women into certain
categories but Lorraine does not fit
into yeah I mean look I get it I love an
emotional story but I think there are
different ways to tell emotional stories
and she's just kind of easy go for that
easy manipulative emotion I mean I am a
movie goer I love going to the movies I
love sitting in a dark room and you know
going to a world and having the people
in that world take you on an emotional
journey but I think that sometimes it
can like I feel like there's a laziness
behind it it's just such easy choices
it's like of course I'm going to care
for this woman if you tell me that her
husband died but what if you don't tell
me our husband died like can you still
have me feel something for her and you
know I think we all have to kind of step
up to the plate and work a little harder
to find interesting choices to have with
women and not go to these very easy
mother nurturer the Madonna [ __ ]
complex place that we've just kind of
lived in for so long what kind of
physical training and shape do you need
to get into before attempting shooting a
scene like that oh it's brutal there's
nothing easy about I I think I I knew
that that would be such a big part of
this film and so I think mentally I was
prepared or as prepared as I could be
for it but once you show up for that
first four hour workout
and you get up in the middle of the
night to go to the toilet and you can't
sit down and and you're like I'm not
going to be able to do this tomorrow and
you show up and you do it again this
time five hours I ate you know I think
it was good for me I think that there's
something in all of us when we push
ourselves to that place where we think
we can't we can't go anymore and that's
definitely where I found myself in this
movie I still wanted it with everything
that was in my body but it took a lot of
work to actually get to that place and
two and a half months later you know I I
saw the first footage I wasn't I didn't
really want to see any of this behind
the scenes stuff that they were shooting
and I saw the first little bit of it and
I got really emotional because that all
that time I was like nobody's going to
buy this and and then seeing that you
know we were actually getting to that
place I felt really confident going into
the film and then once we were shooting
we just kept pushing it and going
further with it there's an end sequence
in this film the big guns shootout
battle that we have in a hotel room and
was never scripted and you know five
days before we shot that David was like
you know let's just I missed like we
haven't done an action scene in a while
let's just turn that into an action
scene and if anybody had ever said that
to me before I would have like a nervous
breakdown and be like I'm not prepared
what are you doing and I was like yeah
let's turn it into a gun battle let's do
that so it was nice to be in that place
physically and mentally you know was
empowering I left this film and I did a
lot of stuff that I never thought I
would be able to do and that was super
empowering for me yes
I think it was your director who told me
you guys it was important to you that
Lorraine fight the way a woman would
actually be fighting in these scenes
which is really cool to think about and
that wasn't like using her environment
or using two hands is that like a
discussion that you guys had ahead of
time yeah I mean I've talked about this
a lot I like I think for me as an actor
it's important to work from a place that
feels grounded in reality I'm not good
when I don't have that weight behind me
and I can kind of find things in my own
life or things that I've observed to
kind of connect with that reality and so
for me it was very important every move
that we have in this in the fight
sequences
I was annoyingly always asking what can
a girl do that could a girl do that and
so I think I drove them crazy after a
while I wanted to make this movie and
not have and let it be as badass as this
and not have anybody come up to us and
say a girl can't do that that was
important to me so I'm here to say girls
can do that
but it is it's interesting you know
there's you'll watch that I never i only
punch with my fist once in this movie
and i actually show you how much that
hurts because punching with your fists
really hurt and for a woman you could
break every bone in your hand by doing
that so i only punch once and it's like
a like a you know it's like a guy that's
already passed out so i'm just kind of
you know being a bit of an a-hole giving
them that last punch but it you know I
was like wow like that hurts because
that's the truth you never see me really
doing that everything I'm using is
either my elbows my knees my entire body
or using my entire body weight to throw
because that's the reality I can't fight
the same way as a guy could fight but
that doesn't mean that I fight any less
or any less better than a man
I know you like to do a lot of these
funds to yourself was there anything
that you regretted trying or anything
that you regretted not trying in the end
well I you know I really wanted to jump
out of the building but the producer in
me was like no but I still kind of wish
I did that I don't know why but it was
so early in the movie and if something
went wrong we would have had to shut the
whole movie down and I didn't want to do
that so I still I mean that's the one
thing I watched in the movie and I'm
like Scott I wish but I'm really really
happy that my stun girl mode did an
excellent job kicking her legs and her
garter belt coming down no I mean look
there was in that fight sequence that
you just saw
you know we trained very specifically
for that but once you throw a camera
operator into the whole mix it changes
everything a little bit you know we were
working with small as really small space
and it was usually three of us in that
space and now you're adding a fourth
person into that space holding a camera
and no I mean I don't regret it at all
but I did with our camera operator and
stunt coordinator you know the scene
where the guy hits me with a bag and I
go down and I twist onto the floor I
fell right onto him and our heads my
head hit the camera and the camera hit
him and the two of us were just kind of
I think just lying on the floor for good
I mean it felt like 20 minutes but it
was probably three seconds that was that
was probably one of the worst things
that have been in that fight yeah stupid
camera operator how is the camera yeah I
know the camera works okay ever was a
little good yeah the human being is not
so much but we pulled it together
another scene in this movie has been
getting a little bit of buzz is there's
a sex scene between you and a very
lovely French agent yeah and I think
that that also plays into the what you
talked about from the beginning about
fine how a spy behaves right I mean have
you been surprised at all that people
have been somewhat taken aback by the
scene um no I mean I guess I guess it's
I mean I have to ask myself would people
ask as much about it if it was a guy I
don't know yeah I don't know the answer
to that and I'm surprised at how much
people like it I like that
very hot scene like I'll everyone man
yeah I like that people you know
appreciate it just I mean you know even
though we wanted to make provocative
choices for this film and to have this
film kind of live and breathe in this
heightened state you know it's vibrant
this is not your grandfather's spy
thriller nobody wears a grey well one
guy does but it's perfect for him you
know we really try to take the genre and
turn it on its head and so not you know
putting this movie aside I just feel in
general that that community is not
necessarily they're not represented in a
way that they should be in film I feel
that you know actors always talk about
holding a mirror up and reflecting
society with the work that we do in
cinema but if we're going to do that we
should really do that and so in a way
you know this could have been I could
have hooked up with a guy but it's great
that I hook up with a girl and I I'm
proud of that I also think that the
story actually gets told in a it gets
further through that relationship more
than it would have ever gotten further
if she had a relationship with a man and
I also love that we never see this
character you know the one time that she
struggles with her humanity and being
vulnerable is in that scene and so
having it be with another woman
I'm happy that it's not with a man yeah
I love that there's not one place in
this movie where them it's because of a
man that she has to like kind of find
her brokenness we're just we're just
trying
to break rules here we're just trying to
kind of see what happens if you take a
woman and throw her in different
circumstances and I think you know it's
not to say that we don't I love me a
lovemaking scene with a man
I love it in my real life I mean so i
got nothing i got nothing against that
but i think that it was good for this
film to see a woman have to struggle
with being vulnerable and have that be
with another woman yeah absolutely
yay for me girls
[Laughter]
so this portrayal of Lorraine has
stirred up talk that you could play
another famous British spy like to read
something your former co-star Chris
Hemsworth said recently to W Magazine he
said I think Charlize Theron should be
the next James Bond there's more she
embodies every ounce of strength and
nobility and dignity and integrity that
that character should have and she's
smart as hell she's physically able I
just think why not it's time so
we have a female doctor who know yeah
right yeah what do you say about uh what
do you think about a female I'm look I'm
all for it I you know I also it feels a
little bit uncomfortable talking about
something like that when I think that
another movie is going to production
hypothetically I think of this character
is something that could hopefully you
know live and breathe in the same kind
of format like we can actually make a
couple of more movies and yes see this
agent lives you know and so I'm fine
with so leaving that over to Daniel or
it's a Idris who I think would be and
I'll do Lorraine but indulge this
fantasy for a second if you were James
Young who would be your first choice as
Bond boy yes well I will make my Bond
boy Aban girl oh op again Jimmy Fallon
already through his name into the Hat oh
good Lois Circle that wants to be Dickie
galore so I'm open I'm open
you know when I went back and started
looking at all of your films something I
think that you don't get enough credit
for is what a good driver you are you
seem to be able to derive you everything
new I've been waiting to do Mini Coopers
try where did this come from I just told
you kicked all of your co-stars ass in
the Italian Job did yes you were the
best one by far Mark Wahlberg Jason
Statham they all puked literally we'd go
on the track and they'd like you know
this is like some stunt driver next to
you and you're got a helmet on and you
just hear and well faster faster if I'm
like who doesn't love this and then I
look I'm passing mark and he's barking
at the back of his car and Jason
Statham's like during a water and
putting her
like these dudes what's wrong with them
I love driving I love I love driving I
you know by the time I was five I could
drive a tractor so that's just growing
up on a farm for you I love driving you
know I I just dig it but thank you thank
you for acknowledging that because girls
get such a bad rep that's true it's time
for us to change that that character was
so incredible and I know that there's
been talk that there's a backstory that
we don't know about what can we do all
together all of us to get George Miller
I know right another story for furiosa
yeah I I'm with you guys this whatever
it is I'll do it with you guys I am
loved playing that character and I love
that George allowed me to play that
character and then he never not for day
fought me on that character and did
nothing but support and celebrate who I
wanted that woman to be and he's just
amazing and it would be great but if
he's not ready then he's not ready so
I'll be waiting George that I'm going to
be 42 in August so let's get to it
that's of it but you know you would
decide you know something about yeah I
read the back story it was a beautiful
back story of kind of how she ended up
you know in in that world and how she
lost her arm and yeah and how she was
kind of how he was trying to utilize her
but couldn't and she was barren and all
of this stuff that you know again we
always think of with women and this was
really a character that kind of played
against all of that stuff and I think
through playing against it to me was a
real woman hi my name is Mike Charlize
like Sarah said you played a lot of
different characters but as far as the
DC or marvel Side what was it was there
any characters you would want to play on
either side no who would you want me to
play who do you think I could play the
females or I mean oh yeah yeah
holy Wow or a DC power of para girl wow
you sure yeah oh my gosh that's nice
thank you you're so welcome
you're oh dude I feel the same about you
what is the favorite role of your career
where you portrayed a villain and then
the favorite role where you portrayed a
hero oh wow you know talking about your
films and how much you like them or not
like them is a little bit like talking
about your kids you know you love them
all but it's just for different reasons
and they give you a hassle for different
things and they make it hard on certain
days I mean I I'll say this I definitely
loved here a hero was so hard because I
don't feel like I've ever played a hero
so I don't know if heroes exist but it
like a real person I would have to say
probably you know I love how conflicted
Aileen Wuornos was in monster I think
just digging into humanity and what
humanity is and that humanity is not
just black and white there is no just
good or bad there are good people who do
bad things and we have to kind of take a
look and see why they do that
I mean I've loved them all you know I I
love the film they did with Niki Caro I
loved I've been lucky enough to work
with great women in this business
I mean villain wise I feel like they're
all a little bit villainous but I had a
blast playing Ravenna I mean Who am I
kidding I just the Wardrobe and I love
just I have that crown the original hero
crown in my office I still wear it every
once in a while my kids don't like it at
all but sorry I don't really know if I
answered you a question sorry I'm all
over the place now thanks thanks to
being a girl we have a lady now
thank you for the opportunity to share
my voice there's been a lot of attention
about unequal pay among actresses in
Hollywood so what's going to actually
make the change and what can we do as
fans to support that well that's a great
question right I feel the support that a
film like Wonder Woman just had that
says so much I mean if anything you
cannot deny that no studio can deny that
and look at that and not saying well we
need to make more movies like that I
feel that there was a there was a big
part because I kind of you know I put my
foot down at some point it was with with
Snow White and the Huntsman or yeah it
was no one in the Huntsman the second
one is that what that one was called I'm
blanking right now I'm old guys I didn't
take my four brain medication this
morning
but anyway Universal was incredible at
that time because they just said of
course you know we're not going to even
have a discussion about this you were in
the first one you're just as much a part
of the success of that as Chris so we're
not going to even have that and and I
think what's was missing in that
conversation or that story that
everybody wrote about was that I am in a
very blessed place where I can choose
when I want to go and work and that's
one of the greatest luxuries that you
can have in life and I don't take that
for granted one day of my life but
there's a whole industry of actresses in
my industry who don't have the luxury of
putting their foot down and saying you
know what I'm not going to come in for
the job because they have families to
support and if they did that the
producers will just move on to the next
girl and that's where we need to stop it
and I think with social media we need to
keep this conversation going I think the
more we talk about this the more
pressure we put on that as being a fact
and the truth in our industry and look
guys I always say to studios and like
make more female driven movies not just
actors directors writers and they always
say well we would if people go and see
them so how can you help go see those
movies I mean that's really how we're
going to get women to kind of take
control of having some kind of an
ownership within any part of our
industry whether it's summer
blockbusters or fall films or comedies
or whatever you know we need you guys to
support us we need you guys to go and
see it when you do guys to understand
that they're just as good we're just as
good as the guys plus we have brewed
they don't have food thank you
you